معك مازن ابراهيم وهذا الاستهداف الاول
لهذه البلده بلده بنت
[موسيقى]
جبيل نعم زين العابدين دعني ابدا البدايه
من مراسم تشيع جنازه ثلاثه شهداء سقطوا في
الاستهداف الاسرائيلي لبلده بنت جبيل انا
اتواجد حاليا في وسط بلده بنت جبيل نشاهد
والد احد الشهداء الذين تم استهدافهم من
قبل طائرات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالامس
فجرا تم اطلاق ثلاثه صواريخ للمره الاولى
من قبل طائرات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على
بلده بنت شبيل والتي
تحمل طابعا رمزيا بالنسبه لحزب الله
ولجمهور المقاومه هنا في لبنان يمكن ان
نشاهد نعش
وجثمان زوجه احد الاشقاء الاثنين الذين تم
استهدافهما من المدنيين من قبل طائرات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي زين العابدين صحيح ان
الجثامين ملفوفه باعلام حزب الله وذلك لان
البيئه الحاضنه في هذه المنطقه كلها سواء
من المدنيين او غير المدنيين تتماهى حاليا
في هذه المعركه مع ما يحصل على مستوى
المواجهه ضد قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هنا
تم تجميع الثانين الثلاثه وسيتم نكرهم بعد
قليل باتجاه المدافن في بلده بنت جبيل هذا
الاستهداف يعتبر الاول من نوعه على مستوى
بنت جبيل
ورمزيتها واطلاق الصواريخ بالنسبه للقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في هذه البلده يهدف
الى ايصال رسائل متعدده الان يمكن ان
نشاهد على محمد وال
محمد زين العابدين
هذه الاحتفاليه اليوم او مراسم الجنازه
اراد حزب الله ان يقيمها بهذا الشكل
الكبير الذي تشاهده حاليا هنا في بلده بنت
شبيل في محاوله لايصال رسائل الى الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اثناء هذه المراسم كان يتم
اطلاق دفعات متتاليه من الصواريخ من
القطاع الشرقي من جنوب لبنان تم اطلاق
المحتله عمليا الرسائل الان هي تنطلق من
جنوب لبنان سواء على مستوى ما نشهده هنا
من مراسم جنازه تشيع الشهداء الثلاثه
الذين سقطوا بالاستهداف الاسرائيلي او من
خلال الصواريخ التي يتم
اطلاقها المناطق المتاخمه للحدود الجنوبيه
للبنان
وعزهم وعز يمكن ان نحرك الكاميرا قليلا كي
نشاهد الجماهير التي احتشدت هنا في وسط
ساحه بنت جبيل علما بان هذه المدينه التي
جرى استهدافها اليوم تقع عند الخطوط
الاماميه للمواجهه مع طول الخط الشريط
الحدودي حيث يتم تنفيذ العمليات بشكل يومي
من قبل حزب الله نتحدث عن مجموعه كبيره من
العمليات التي تم تنفيذها سواء ال خلال
اليوم او خلال يوم امس وعلما بانه خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين ارتفعت بشكل كبير نسبه
العمليات التي يتم تنفيذها من قبل حزب
الله وباتت المعادله متسعه وقواعد
الاشتباك تتغير يوميا بمعنى ان
الاستهدافات التي ينفذها حزب الله بدات
كبيره بشكل كبير وهي ما ادت الى ايقاع هذا
العدد الكبير من قبل المقاومه في صفوف
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نتحدث عن اكثر
من 60
وفق الاعلانات الرسميه لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في هذه العمليات التي تم
تنفيذها كذلك الامر بالنسبه لما تم اعلانه
على مستوى القتله وبالتالي هذه هي
المشهديه هنا في القرى الحدوديه وتحديدا
من خلال هذه الرسائل التي اراد حزب الله
ايصالها سواء من خلال مراسم التشييع هنا
رغم القصف الذي تعلت له البلده او من خلال
الصواريخ التي جرى اطلاقها بشكل متتال
وعلى دفعات
كبيره ابقى معنا مازن ابراهيم تحدثت عن
رمزيه بنت جبيل وهذا الاستهداف الاول لهذه
المدينه التي القي فيها في عام 2000 خطاب
النصر بعد الانسحاب الاسرائيلي خطاب حسن
نصر الله وايضا كان لها دور بارس في معركه
عام
2006 معركه بنت شبيل